hello freak [ __ ] I was saying that
marijuana can be your friend and it can
enhance your life but if if you take too
much it's it's such a seductive little
creature a little bit of it is like ah
this is nice this feels good but if you
get too crazy especially if you get too
crazy with edibles it'll take you and
take you away on this wild journey of
paranoia and and you'll it'll lock you
up like some people just need to take a
couple of weeks off just relax that's
always a good idea right yeah yeah I
think people underestimate cannabis I
think it can be like you say it can
really sort of knock you off your Center
especially if it's edible and like all
these things you gotta learn how to use
it yeah I mean it's basically that's
what you gotta do you have to learn how
to use it but you know you know that's
my raps yeah it's a great rap it really
is it's so important it's I think it's
so important for people to realize that
you got to let like regular you like you
like natural sober you it's important to
be in touch with that like you don't
want to always be high or always be
caffeinated or always be anything well
exactly I mean we're you know people get
you know to these places and they fail
to do a reality check on themselves you
know I mean I get emails from people all
the time so well I'm you know life's
been pretty weird lately
I took mushrooms five times last week
and you know I was and it's like dude
how about you lay off for a while give
yourself a chance because you know they
tell these stories of it's like the idea
of okay let's find your Center go back
to baseline lay off the sauce whatever
it is you're taking and just chill out
and try and reef rediscover your Center
it seems like common sense advice but
people don't do it does seem like common
sense advice but common sense is not
common yes all you have to do is look
around what is it about people though
that once they indulge in any sort of a
minute
doesn't even have to be a substance it
could be an activity like gambling for
instance like once it gets in your bones
it just seems like you're so compelled
to just continue that behavior and and
the idea of stopping is almost more
painful than the idea of wrecking your
life this this is this is addiction yeah
this is basically these things are
reinforcing they activate those pleasure
circuits you know in in the brain
mediated mainly through dopamine and all
of these I mean that the so-called drugs
of abuse which I think is a terrible
work terrible but you know the
reinforcing drugs the pleasure drugs
work directly or indirectly through the
dopamine circuits and the dopamine is
like your your button for pleasure you
know in the same way that serotonin it's
kind of on the opposite side it's your
button for more like euphoria feeling
good but not the it doesn't have the the
punch
I guess that the which is why people can
get addicted to gambling they can get
addicted to sex they can get addicted to
television all of these things it
doesn't have to be substances because
they all hit those same circuits
you know except the psychedelics which
don't work on that reward circuitry they
work on a different set of circuits but
yet even with those your behavior
patterns can become addictive and then
you can start just doing psychedelics
too much and it's not even the
psychedelics that are doing it it's just
this compulsive need to constantly
change your state of mind yeah that's
quite true and if people you know the
way to use psychedelics is is there are
many ways to use it but basically use it
the thoughtfully you know I mean you can
all the question about recreational use
versus spiritual use versus therapeutic
use I mean these are all ways to
approach it
and I am NOT a person who says you must
do it this way you must do it that way
what I do say is do it from an informed
place and do approach it thoughtfully
you know because I mean in other words
don't
you know plan for it respect the
medicine in a certain way you know use
it in a circumstance where you can learn
from the medicine rather than have the
medicine be sort of a you know overlay
up over whatever else you're doing I
mean this is something that demands
attention and I think that's the best
way to use psychedelics and for whatever
you know whatever spin you put on it is
it spiritual as a therapeutic is it
recreational is it shamanic these are
all labels the important thing is that
you know you you have the you approach
the medicine itself the medicine is the
teacher right not the sitter not the
shaman that's the psychotherapist if
they're doing the right their job
correctly in my opinion their job is to
let you have your encounter with the
medicine and the medicine is what you
learn from they're there to facilitate
that they can intervene if you get
anxious sort of things go on make sure
you know nobody comes to the door that
kind of thing but basically it's to
facilitate a learning opportunity where
you and your teacher which is the
medicine Viet ayahuasca or mushrooms or
whatever can have this intense
one-on-one interaction you know I feel
like with psychedelics as well as with
all these other things that we're
talking about any kind of drug you mean
even coffee alcohol whatever and
behavior patterns all these different
things I think one of the things that
happens with human beings is you get so
far along in your life in these behavior
patterns become so like tight grooves
that are carved into your psyche and
then as you become an adult then you
start to learn like oh there's got to be
a better way to handle this let me
figure out how to do this and it's
almost like getting a car when you're
really young and not learning how to
drive until you like in your 20s right
and so you're just driving this thing
it's smashing the trees and grinding the
gears and then somewhere along the line
you like oh my god I'm [ __ ] myself up
I have to figure out a way to do this
correctly and there's two different
approaches
one the abstinence approach which is
very popular people say well I'm I'm
straightedge now I don't do anything and
that's it and I just you know I just do
wheatgrass and I run hills and stuff I'm
like okay you could do that too I mean
right you can do it you definitely can
do that too but it's I just don't think
that there's anything wrong with any of
these things I think there's something
wrong with the way we use them and I
think it's one of the inherent problems
with things being illegal mm-hmm is that
we can't discuss this we don't have
people like you or centers where people
can go where people can become educated
on the proper way to use these drugs or
medicines or whatever you want to call
them these compounds and get something
out of them they can really be
beneficial right that's that's exactly
right I mean I've said this many many
times that you know drug education what
they call drug education in this country
is a joke because the whole emphasis is
on don't use them that's absurd that's
like telling you know an eighteen year
old guy full of testosterone don't have
sex right don't come on it's built into
the genetics they're gonna go for that
what you have to do what they can't
bring themselves to acknowledge in the
drug education field is it's not about
telling people not to use drugs it's
about teaching people how to use drugs
if they choose to right I mean like any
other skill people have to learn to
drive they have to learn to do yoga they
have to learn to do whatever they do
there's an educational process I tell
people many times you know my stick is
there is no such thing as a bad drug and
that's another problem with the dialogue
the badness is projected onto the drugs
drugs are simply compounds with a
certain pharmacology there's no moral
aspect to them the moral dimension comes
and how do people use them that's where
you know it's human behavior that's
moral or immoral like I say you know
there's no such thing as a bad drug
plenty of bad ways to use drugs you know
but that comes from the person not the
compound
[Applause]
[Music]